bonjour en fait je suis en train
d'écrire le scénario de time warp la
saison 2 voilà prête utilisent des pâtes
alphabet étant donné que pour l'instant
on n'a pas de budget c'est vrai que
c'est un petit peu compliqué d'avoir du
bon matériel
alors c'est un petit peu long et c'est
un petit peu compliqué mais bon bah on
s'adapte on fait comme on peut mais
c'est vrai que ça serait quand même
vachement bien d'avoir un petit peu de
budget par si je peux me permettre si si
si jamais vous avez envie de nous aider
à monter ce projet correctement et avoir
du bon matériel et bien n'hésitez pas à
nous aider sur le projet et l'uil ça
serait vraiment super et sam
économiserait beaucoup de temps
merci